on this wednesday night the legal
challenges of laying terrorism charges
in the london killings
mounting pressure on the police the
motive needs to be either
ideological political or religious
and the legacy of the family that was
killed he's probably helped thousands of
families
heated debate over quebec secularism law
how the london attack is reigniting
criticism
about bill 21 rules soon to be relaxed
i want to see myself making it easier
for canadians to come back home
plus trunks on a trek the elephants
attracting a mammoth audience
[Music]
global national with donna friesen
[Music]
in london ontario people are still
leaving flowers and standing in silence
at the site where four members of one
family were run down and killed by a man
in his pickup truck
a deliberate act the police say
motivated by hate
there are demands to move beyond acts of
condolence and kind words
to concrete political action
this is not the first time this has
happened it has happened several times
and it continues to happen
so what's going to happen how are things
going to be different tomorrow
than what they were on sunday rhetoric
is not enough anymore it's not going to
change anything
good evening and thanks for joining us
funeral plans are underway the community
is still reeling and the nine-year-old
boy who lost his parents his sister and
his grandmother
is still in the hospital recovering from
his injuries in our top story tonight
jeff semple hears how the community is
coping
as new details emerge about the murder
suspect
fifteen-year-old yumna ufsal was a
student at the london islamic school
the principal says she and her mother
spent countless hours last summer
painting this mural the budding artist
wanted to turn the blank wall in her
homeroom
into something beautiful they also chose
a quote
shoot for the moon even if you miss
you'll land among the stars
yumna also with the same paint assigned
her name there
it's symbolic of who she was of who the
family was
and the real big legacy
of stopping hate that's in front of us
on sunday night while out for a walk
with her family yumna was allegedly
murdered by this pickup truck
along with her grandmother and her
parents her father
salman was a physiotherapist very humble
man very unassuming
he worked to rehabilitate seniors in
long-term care homes
including this one and to have somebody
of that caliber and that commitment to
seniors and all of a sudden that that
loss
to our communities is you know
staggering the lone survivor of the
attack nine-year-old fayez
whose photo we're not showing at the
request of the family
is recovering in hospital and he's just
been told that his family
didn't survive my conversations with the
family he is their focus
this family spokesperson says the boy
has relatives in the area and the
community has raised more than a million
dollars
a number of complete strangers have also
already offered
to adopt him you can never replace your
parents
but i hope things will
he will have the support he needs to
move forward in his life
the family's accused murderer had
purchased his truck
just a few weeks earlier from this
dealership after the attack
police say the driver took off for
several kilometers
before stopping in this mall parking lot
the car
the cab was parked right there the
president of the local taxi company says
one of his drivers was standing outside
his parked car
when the suspect pulled up right behind
him the front of the truck was covered
in blood
the guy says with bad language
insulting him profanity f words and
stuff
called police i killed someone
the cab driver said the suspect
nathaniel veltman was wearing an armored
vest
and a military helmet when police
removed the vest
the cab driver says he saw a symbol on
the suspect's
shirt my colleague explained that
he had a swastika signs on his
front on his chest and his back as well
but he said he was laughing
the entire time as he was being
dragged out of the car police would not
confirm those details but say
evidence from his arrest helped to lead
them to the conclusion
that the family was targeted because of
their islamic
faith it was pretty clear from the the
investigation that occurred
immediately at the scene so without
getting into the details of what
what evidence came from all that we were
fairly comfortable at an early stage
attributing to this to to being a hate
and motivated crime
jeff semple is with me from london jeff
the police investigation
is ongoing what happens next
well donna next up the suspect will make
an appearance in court here
tomorrow expected to be pretty brief to
set a date for a bail hearing
in the meantime police are now reviewing
what they say is quite a lot of video
footage that was recorded by
surveillance cameras in the area as well
as smartphones from people
who happen to be here at the site the
night of the attack and the police chief
told me today
that they're particularly interested now
in the suspect's online
footprint his thought process leading up
to this attack
and whether the revelations there might
help them to add another charge
of terrorism donna
all right jeff semple in london ontario
thanks
camille caramalli is also in london
tonight camille you've been talking to a
spokesperson
for the family i know they are very
private what
are they willing to share with the
public
yeah that's right donna the family
spokesperson did say the family was very
overwhelmed by the show of support at
last night's vigil thousands and
thousands of people
showed up to show their support for the
family the extended family of the
deceased they were not there but they
were watching
from afar now they watched and listened
from home they said and felt a sense of
hope
and show of support a family friend is
also sharing more about the family today
he said the father
that salman afzo was the friendliest guy
imaginable
his wife meanwhile was incredibly
hard-working raising children supporting
her husband's
physiotherapy practice and getting her
phd in civil engineering now friends and
family that they say they can't believe
this tragedy happened
to a family that put so much good out
into the world
but when it happens to a family like
that
it's that much more you know
painful that these people who only did
good to society
they only did good to others they were
the ones
who
who got the consequences of this hate
emily you've also spoken to the imam at
the mosque in london
and well he's grateful for all the
support he is calling for more concrete
action what did he tell you
absolutely and that's what they're
asking for we've heard a lot of rhetoric
from politicians but they're asking
right now for tangible
change real change so that they can feel
safe
the muslim community can feel safe out
on the streets and now the national
canadian council of muslims they've
started a petition
and they're calling on all levels of
government to come together for a
national action summit on combating
islamophobia and they're hoping that
will
stir up some real concrete changes
if they're making promises and if they
they say that they're going to be
changes
then that is our expectation because
this is not about politics this is about
the lives of
of innocent human beings it's about a
sense of safety and security
and the family uh spokesperson has also
told me
that there is a funeral plan for all
four of those
victims but they're not sharing the when
and where publicly donna because they
really want it to be very private and
very personal
back over to you all right camille
caramalli in london thanks
well many people including the prime
minister have called what happened a
terrorist act and that's led to lots of
questions about why
terrorism charges have not been laid the
answer
is complex as mercedes stevenson
explains
terrorism is the word that comes to mind
for many canadians when they think about
what happened in london on sunday night
including the prime minister this was a
terrorist attack
public or political sentiment is not the
bar for laying a criminal charge though
no matter how clear-cut it might seem
the quebec mosque shootings that left
six worshipping muslims dead
the toronto van attack targeting women
that killed
10 people were the stabbing and vehicle
rampage in edmonton in 2017
inspired by isis violent acts that
appeared to be inspired by clear beliefs
yet none led to criminal terror charges
so what does it take motive
is key the motive needs to be either
ideological
political or religious in whole or in
part
terror charges also require a violent
act
and courts want evidence there was an
intent to intimidate
or terrorize the accused watching videos
or making comments online
may not be enough to convince a jury of
what the attacker
truly believed that can lead police and
prosecutors
to choosing other charges they can get a
conviction on
and that carry a tougher sentence than
terrorism charges
for first degree murder his sentence is
an automatic life sentence with no
eligibility for
parole for 25 years so it has the most
stringent sentence of any offense in the
criminal code
i understand that there is a component
of
faith and terrorism connection to all
this but first-degree murder
carries the most severe penalty but some
national security experts say
prosecutors
should consider using terrorism charges
to send a message
that prosecutors need to be considering
the denunciation and the deterrence of
terrorist violence perpetrated against
minority communities any potential
terrorism charges in this case
could take days to months to be laid as
police dig through the evidence
but even acts which inflict terror may
not result
in terror charges donna all right
mercedes
thanks now to the pandemic and steps
towards loosening restrictions at the
border in july canadian citizens
and permanent residents flying back into
the country won't have to stay at a
government-approved
quarantine hotel if they are fully
vaccinated
michael couture explains i want to see
myself my other half
like this person sarah anderson is
american while her partner and step
children
are canadian already separated by the
canada-us border
pandemic restrictions and a 14-day
quarantine
mean a five-hour drive from minneapolis
to thunder bay
turns into a three-week ordeal so at
this point now
we're kind of back to where we were last
year where we can't
see each other because neither one of us
can at this time take off the
15-day requirement around the first week
of july fully vaccinated canadian
citizens or permanent residents
returning home by air
no longer have to stay in one of those
government-approved hotels
they can also stop the 14-day quarantine
once the pcr test they take upon arrival
comes back negative nothing yet for the
next steps
in reopening the border it is better now
to be slow and cautious to use
the best science and evidence to be
careful
in our approach so that we can have a
sustained success
now once 75 percent of canadians have
one dose of vaccine and 20 percent have
two
officials say more restrictions could be
eased
and there is a metric for when canada
may reopen the border
to tourists the next uh goal post on
that front that uh we'll be assessing is
around when we
achieve the 75 to those for
the eligible um population for
vaccinations so
that is going to be taken into account
now anderson is fully vaccinated and has
a family exemption
but is still unsure if the changes
announced apply to her
and without more details from the
canadian government it's hard to blame
her
now the federal government is working
with the provinces and territories on a
type of vaccine passport so that
canadians can provide proof of
vaccination
upon arrival but that passport will only
be good
if you've been given vaccines approved
by health canada
michael couture global news ottawa
it's been on life support for years now
the keystone xl pipeline expansion
project is officially dead
calgary-based tc energy says it's
pulling the plug and will work with
government agencies to ensure
safe termination of an exit from the
partially built pipeline
first proposed in 2008 it was supposed
to transport crude from alberta oil
sands to nebraska and onto the u.s
gulf coast it has run into multiple
hurdles and when u.s
president joe biden was elected he
canceled the permits
alberta invested 1.5 billion dollars in
the project
last year a proposed settlement for some
former residential school students
coming up news they and their families
have been waiting years for
the other children and i were physically
and verbally abused for speaking our
native languages
the staff told me that speaking
schweppes gene
was a heathen activity
that's deanna jewell she was a day
student at the residential school in
kamloops bc
it robbed her and thousands of other
indigenous children of their language
and their cultural identity she's one of
many day scholars kids who went to
residential schools but lived close by
and went home at night
they've finally reached a proposed
settlement in a class-action lawsuit
against the federal government
david aiken explains what they'll get
and what it means not just for survivors
but for their descendants deena jules
was the third generation of her family
to be sent to the kamloops residential
school
she started there when she was seven i
endured five years as a day scholar
and one year as a resident these
years were the dark ages of my life
all the students be they overnight
residents or day scholars who went home
each night
were treated the same beaten and abused
if they used their own language or
acknowledge their own culture
they called me a pagan and dumb indian
and told me that i needed to become more
white
we were children we did not deserve
the treatment that we or i received from
the priests
brothers and the sisters now
dina jules charlotte gilbert and between
twelve thousand and twenty thousand
other day scholars or their descendants
will receive a one-time payment of
ten thousand dollars as compensation for
the harm they suffered
the result of an out-of-court settlement
in a lawsuit that dates back
to 2012. i became disconnected from my
family and community
i lost language my cultural pride
and my own identity in addition to the
individual compensation
the federal government will set up a 50
million dollar fund
to be managed by indigenous leaders for
other reconciliation projects
it's my sincere hope that this will
unlock
a healing process for all those involved
but even though the day scholars class
action suit is settled
government lawyers still oppose
residential school survivors and
indigenous children
in several other lawsuits the ndp along
with indigenous advocates say
the federal government should do what it
did with the day scholars
pull back the lawyers and settle david
aiken global news
ottawa still ahead can you condemn
islamophobia yet try to pass a law that
critics say
stokes it ahead a deeper look at
quebec's bill c-21
the attack in london has renewed calls
to tackle racism and end policies that
allow it to flourish
but it has put quebec's bill 21 squarely
in the crosshairs the legislation
prohibits many public sector workers
such as police and teachers from wearing
religious symbols or clothing
while at work it's put lots of pressure
on politicians
mike armstrong reports it isn't a clear
question of cause and effect but some
say it's climate
could quebec's controversial bill 21
legitimize
discrimination to the point it pushes
hatred
oh i absolutely link link the two
together
has been fighting the secularism law
since it was first tabled in march of
2019.
it effectively bans anyone who wears
religious symbols
from working for the government in a
position of authority someone who wears
a kippah a turban or a hijab
can't be a teacher a police officer or a
judge lataef says it leads to feelings
of us and other it contributes
very strongly to the atmosphere that
creates a fertile ground
for such mentalities such such hate such
incidents
in quebec under bill 21. bill 21 was
brought up at tuesday's vigil the head
of the national council of canadian
muslims
calls it aggressively discriminatory
legislation
when things like what happens in london
happen
they don't just happen out of a vacuum
they happen in a context
now the linking of bill 21 and london
has become a hot topic in quebec media
with many blaming
english journalists for pushing a
narrative do you agree with what the
prime minister was asked three questions
tuesday about bill 21
and the climate it creates davao the
head of the black quebecois says there's
no way to know if the alleged attacker
had ever heard
of bill 21 and he says linking them is
quebec bashing
bill 21 has no meaning in london ontario
it's disgusting that uh people would try
to make this some sort of angle
versus franco issue my disagreement
the prime minister has said he opposes
the bill but won't fight it in court
he's leaving that to citizens and
advocacy groups
premier says the bill is popular in the
province and ottawa should stay out of
the debate
some polls have pegged support for the
bill at above 60 percent
that is likely a factor keeping the
federal liberals from taking too strong
a stance
against it mike armstrong global news
montreal
those elephants in china that are
roaming through cities are still
on the move and a drone has caught them
snuggled up in a forest for a
well-deserved nap
except for the little one who seems wide
awake drones are being
used to track the elephants the herd of
15 has tracked about 500 kilometers
since leaving their nature reserve last
year their
natural habitat is vanishing don't you
wander too far
we're back in a moment
we have reported on attacks motivated by
hate far too often
and every time we hear the refrain never
again
then it happens again there is much that
has to change and
much we all have to learn each one of us
is part of that process and it includes
listening
even if what you hear makes you
uncomfortable we leave you with voices
from london ontario
[Music]
inshallah healing can come out of this
through the prayer allah has guided us
to say
[Music]
faith is at the heart of the reason we
are here today
it was faith that was targeted and it is
in faith that we draw strength
we are always canadians we're always
together we're always united
this minority hate that
is out there is not going to overtake
[Music]
love is greater than hate
and hate can be overcome and for those
of you who still have hate
in your hearts we want more for you
[Music]
we will be resilient by being normal
by being ourselves we will heal
my sister would not have wanted us to
live in fear with wearing our hijabs
she would have wanted us to be proud of
our identities
she would have wanted us to unite
together to stand for what is right
i'll leave you with the words of yumna
my student from last year
she said i want to leave a legacy
she proceeded to paint a mural in the
mosque
that reads shoot for the moon even if
you miss
you'll land among the stars it's
symbolic
it's symbolic of who she was of who the
family was
and the real big legacy
of stopping hate that's in front of us
the journey we're about to take
is is is the real legacy that they left
[Music]